straight ahead on law and crime daily we
do not believe that he got a fair shake
at any point in time so-called sex cult
leader keith raniere
is recovering from coven 19 in prison
the defense attorneys
preparing his appeal there are more
pieces to each one of these stories
we're not downplaying the allegations a
california man accused of murdering his
estranged wife
is now accused of threatening a
prosecutor and his family
the defense disagrees i do not believe
that he's in danger
the trial of wisconsin man charged with
killing his wife abruptly put on hold
while a judge recovers judge hinqvist
slipped and fell last night returning
home from work
we'll tell you when testimony is set to
resume law on crime daily covering court
cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
convicted sex cult leaders keith reniere
is recovering from kova 19
as his defense prepares their appeal
he started exhibiting symptoms endured a
full-blown
covert 19 breakout if you will
or shakes fevers the whole nine yards
criminal defense attorney joseph mcbride
represents keith ranieri
mcbride a frequent guest on the law and
crime network believes rainier
contracted coven 19
being transferred between prisons from
new york to arizona
our team had previously requested from
the district court
for mr ranieri to be able to stay back
on the east coast so that his defense
team could have access to him
rene is serving 120-year sentence for
sex trafficking and racketeering
prosecutors say the self-help guru known
as vanguard
recruited celebrities and socialites in
his company called nexium
then forced women to act as sex slaves
ranieri
really you know twisted people's trust
and their need to find
some meaning and hope in their lives in
just the most insidious and devious ways
renire has a new team of attorneys
including mcbride
jennifer bojon who's also leading bill
cosby's appeal
and steven metcalf they say they have
grounds to overturn his conviction
and sentence you have a legitimate
business that's operating with hundreds
of people who are benefiting from it
and are actually gaining
tremendous life experiences as a result
of it and employed
and all of a sudden that becomes deemed
the federal rico
that federal rico the charges that could
relate to
sex trafficking charges 100 percent
tainted the entire proceedings going
forward
from the beginning to the end it had
chilling effects
on the defense that could have been
presented
or that keith could have presented
you're talking about a person that
over 15 victims came forward to testify
against
five of women in his inner circle pled
guilty to
to him exchanging sexual favors in
nexium his company with these women and
branding some of them
and the allegations of i'm gonna keep
this piece of video
of you uh to blackmail in one way or
another
that's not people's feelings i would
argue that's just
what came out i i don't see how that's
like
interpreted differently yeah but brian
those those weren't used
as part of the government's proof those
were used as a part of
showing and establishing restitution and
how that
ultimately led a judge to sentence this
man to 120 years
so that impacted even the judge's view
and ultimately led to that sentencing
the evidence presented at trial to
produce
and substantiate these charges was
completely different
than those victim impact statements and
that's what
we are claiming was lacking at the trial
level
actress allison mack and segrum liquors
heir claire bronfman
both pled guilty to their roles in the
group as for renier the court already
imposed a 1.75 million dollar fine
and prosecutors are seeking additional
restitution for victims
his crimes in the crimes of his
co-conspirators
ruined marriages careers
fortunes and lives there are a lot of
questions
there are a lot of holes we have a lot
of questions about
uh the fbi's work in this case people
here
were hurt on some level the but
the question is about criminality
the question is about proving each
element of each crime beyond a
reasonable doubt
we don't think that the government did
that in this case
um and i'm just gonna sort of leave that
answer right there
here to discuss keith rainier's upcoming
appeal is defense attorney dina dahl and
terry austin
terry what's your reaction to what his
lawyers are saying
could there be some sort of appellate
issue in renee's case
you know brian i don't see it as you
know for a criminal case to win on
appeal you have to have either
legal error you have to have jury
misconduct or you have to have an
assistance of counsel and i don't see
any of those things here i will admit
though that the judge was
somewhat biased against the defendant
here at one point he screamed
you know you're done at the attorney but
that would have been grounds for a
mistrial i don't see grounds for an
appeal
and we know for a fact as you said in
the clip other two defendants have
already pled guilty so i don't see any
grounds for appeal here
now dean maybe not turning over the
entire sentence
but part of the appeal could be the
years that was sentenced to 120 years
is a lot could they not simply say hey
reduce it to 60 years and would that not
be a win
in some way you know as a federal case
here that i'm sure there was federal
sentencing guidelines involved
so it's very hard to overturn the length
of a sentence the judge does have
discretion
and they would have to show some sort of
abuse with discretion which it does not
sound like they have
all right we're going to keep eyes on
this case uh terry
when we're thinking about this appeal
obviously there's any arguments made but
are you still feeling
that the ruling will stand you know i
think they have to make the argument
because you have to do
everything you can for your client but i
think the ruling is going to definitely
stand
all right of course we're going to have
joseph mcbride and stephen metclav
coming back
if there is any updates in this case
make sure to tune in here at the long
crime daily
still ahead on law and crime daily the
nobody murder trial briefly put on pause
but first should a convicted murderer be
granted parole
his defense says he's not a danger the
prosecutor says his own life is at stake
our exclusive reporting next
a deputy d.a in los angeles is trying to
keep a man he prosecuted for murder
behind bars
over threats he made to kill him and his
family but
as angenette levy tells us the man's
attorney does not believe william terry
bradford
ever made the threats yeah that's right
brian you know los angeles deputy
district attorney john lewin has been
saying for many years that william terry
bradford threatened to kill him
and his family when he first got to
prison back in 2002
bradford is now 87 years old and the
california parole board says he should
be released from prison
but his defense attorney says that he is
not a danger
i am here not as a representative
of the los angeles county district
attorney's office
the opinions addressed are my own
and my own only lewin has made a career
out of prosecuting cold case murders
he's prosecuting robert durst for the
murder of his friend susan berman
lewin says bradford whom he prosecuted
in 2002 for the murder of his wife joan
14 years earlier
made threats to another inmate when he
first got to prison
you know i've done a lot of of murder
cases in my career
and that's the only time that i've ever
had a someone i prosecuted who
um has made a threat like that and the
only time that
i've ever really thought that you know i
had a reason to be concerned
the bradfords were in the middle of a
messy divorce when bradford shot joan
from behind in her home
their children found their mother's body
lewin says he and the children fear what
could happen
if bradford is released the man was
willing to throw his life away
at age 55 when he had a million dollar
retirement
so now you know he's in his mid 80s with
nothing to lose
and you want to parole him i will tell
you that my position is that john
lewin's fear
is as absolutely not warranted defense
attorney maya evac says that bradford
suffers from dementia and has limited
mobility
she also points to polygraph test
results for the inmate who claimed
bradford wanted to kill lewin
he was deemed truthful months later when
he said he did not hear bradford
threaten to kill lewin
but had previously said bradford wanted
to kill him and his family
here is this anomaly in in the course of
a divorce a contentious divorce there is
this
um this murder atrocious murder
absolutely
but mr bradford was sentenced to life
with the possibility of parole and that
is that means just that
now after receiving those polygraph
documents from attorney maya emig i went
back to john lewin
he i showed them to him and he said that
he had been under the impression
since back in 2002 2003 that that
inmate passed the polygraph test when he
was asked
whether or not the bradford had ever
threatened to murder him
and his family and he thought that that
inmate said yes
he now sees that the inmate said no he
didn't hear that and basically recanted
those statements
now the inmate um or pardon me governor
newsom rather
he actually reversed the parole board's
decision back in 2018 when the board
said that bradford should be released
then i contacted newsome's office and a
spokesperson there
said that they will again review this
case very carefully
brian thanks internet back with us is
our panel law and crime analyst dina
dahl and co-host terry austin but first
internet break this down for me lewin
knew what
when exactly uh
again he said that back in 2002 2003
he was under the impression and he's
been under the impression the entire
time
that that inmate passed the polygraph
and said at the time
that he had heard bradford make these
statements
he later said during that polygraph no
he had not heard them lewin said he was
not aware of that until we showed him
the documents
so he's going to be deciding what his
next step is and this is important
because john lewin
under marcy's law out in california he
isn't entitled to go to the parole board
and say anything now the children of the
bradfords have designated him
as their representative and he speaks on
their behalf and they are very fearful
of their father and do not want him
released
dina interesting turn of events if the
threats to lewin and his family were
false
what do you think the parole board will
do
you know it's interesting maybe
you know it sounds like he's also
representing the children and that to me
seems like maybe more likely
although two years ago we know that
wasn't enough the threat
to the children so if it does turn out
that this polygraph
all along you know we know polygraphs
are not reliable but if it does turn out
that he didn't actually say that
threaten lewin
then he may be released now terry
convicts rarely get released to the
parole when they first are eligible as
we heard this is not
bradford's first time so do you think a
second go around or multiple goal rounds
may increase his chances
here's my view brian i say keep him
in jail i know he's an older person and
he may not be
a threat to society because of that but
i think the parole board should
err on the side of caution here if
there's any chance
that he actually said i'm going to kill
you attorney
and i'm going to kill your family as
well that's a threat to society so i
think that
perhaps he should at least for now at
least this time around
stay behind bars all right we'll keep
eye on that i know angenette is in touch
with uh
d.a lewin and we'll see how he uh
navigates this parole board with this
new information
thank you all coming up on law and crime
daily a suspect charged with fatally
hitting rapper nicki minaj's father
and fleeing the scene plus an iowa
farmer was convicted of killing his wife
with a corn rake
so why does he have a fan group a report
you don't want to miss
still ahead
[Music]
an arrest has been made in the hit and
run that killed rapper nicki minaj's
father
terry austin is here with new details of
the alleged driver in the fatal crash
police in new york say that after the
crash the suspect actually got out of
his car
stood over the deceased man asked if he
was okay
and then drove home according to the
nassau county police department
70 year old charles polkovic turned
himself
in polkovic is also accused of parking
his car
in his garage to try to hide it from
investigators
robin mirage the father of nicki minaj
was struck and killed while walking
along a road in long island
around 6 pm last friday the 64 year old
was taken to a hospital
and later pronounced dead polkovic was
later identified as the driver
he's facing charges of leaving the scene
of an accident with the fatality
and tampering with evidence
the rogue former fbi agent convicted of
aiding the infamous mobster
james whitey bulger has been granted a
conditional release
from prison john connolly was found
guilty and sentenced
to 40 years for leaking information to
bolger that led to the shooting death of
a gambling executive
a florida commission voted to release
conoley who has cancer
and is believed to have less than a year
to live bulgur was serving out a life
sentence for the murders
of 11 people when he himself was
murdered in 2018.
the family of a former nfl player found
deceased in a hotel room
believes he was suffering from chronic
alcoholism and concussions
the hillsborough county sheriff's office
says 38-year-old vincent jackson
was found dead by an employee of the
hotel last week
jackson played 12 seasons in the nfl
last five for the tampa bay buccaneers
the sheriff's office says he had checked
into the hotel on january 11
and his family reported him missing
about a month later
deputies conducted a welfare check on
february 12 and confirmed his well-being
no apparent signs of trauma were
reported an autopsy report is pending
is an iowa farmer really innocent of
killing his wife with a cornrake chief
investigative correspondent brian ross
spoke to a woman who's on a mission to
prove just that
thanks brian coming up this week i'm
brian ross investigates
rock stars movie stars professional
athletes all have their fan clubs
well so do accused and convicted killers
as we discovered as we put together a
ten part series for an a
e called killer cases we focused on the
case of todd mullis a farmer in iowa
convicted of killing his wife with a
pitchfork
she fell on a fork i absolutely love him
it was very difficult to buy that story
amy was quite unhappy and was
actually thinking about leaving todd
there were aspects of an affair
you believe the last time you saw her
that you did have some type of sexual
relation we started watching the first
day and i was
hooked todd mullis looking at a big
penalty if he's convicted
you know the case kind of took off it
was compelling
and could not believe that this man was
being tried for this
he couldn't have killed her that's
coming up this week brian on brian ross
investigates
on the long crime trial network brian
thanks brian when we come back breaking
down the testimony in a no-body murder
trial
why it's put on hold and what it will
resume after the break
the tribal wisconsin man accused of
killing his wife has been put on pause
while the judge recovers from an
unexpected injury
james procopovich is charged with first
degree intentional homicide of his wife
victorio procopovich she was reported
missing on april 25
2013 and her remains are yet to be
recovered
day four the trial was delayed after the
judge broke his ankle
testimony is expected to resume on
monday prosecutors have called a series
of witnesses
in an effort to show that the defendant
purposely murdered his wife
and hid her body friends say he failed
to help search crews look for her
i went out into the woods where we
searched
with a group of volunteers
do you remember how many people were
volunteering oh gosh
probably 40 50. we had gone outside
you know people were coming in and out
so a lot of them had gone outside so i
went outside as well
they were smoking and just talking i
heard him say
you guys are wasting your time she's
nowhere around here
and you will never find her and he also
said
women all they do is they have nothing
to
do about they find it and those were
comments you recall
mr prokopovic's making during the first
search you were at absolutely those are
etched in my memory
did you observe mr pocapo that's
participated in any of those searches
he did not go on the searches what was
he
doing that you could observe just kind
of walking
around a little bit and then he was gone
on cross the defense pointed out that
she only gave these statements in march
of 2020
that's seven years after the search
i'm just curious you you made a
statement you said the statements were
etched in my memory but when
the prosecution asked you about the
statements you couldn't remember them so
they really aren't etched in your memory
are they
well it is well you had to refresh your
memory to remember what
your statements were correct one of them
yes two of them actually
because there's three statements and you
read two of them
correct right so there was one more
right you remembered the first one
says she's not around here and then you
had to get your memory refreshed for the
other two correct
i don't recall okay sorry you've never
met jim pocapovic prior to these
searches
i have not you've never interacted with
him or know his demeanor
no you don't know what his personality
is like or how he mourns do you
no and him being kind of upset
making these statements could be just
part of his personality as being an
older gentleman correct
no i i was shocked to hear that and
since you're stacy's friend
you're trying to help stacy in marshall
correct
in finding their mother yes
no delays and analysis joining us is
dina dahl and terry austin dina
as we wish the judge a speedy recovery
prosecutors were really trying to get
off any excuse that victoria just
disappeared
but have they done that beyond a
reasonable doubt so far
i mean so far i don't think they have i
mean as we just saw right there the
defense did a really good job of poking
holes into her testimony but the delay
during the prosecution's case is
actually quite helpful to the
prosecution
because lawyers continue to work the
trial
during the trial i mean often at night
the lawyer after the trial ends
you know tweaks the case and prepares it
for the next day
so they know the holes they have in
their case and they have a few days here
to try to plug those holes
to maybe alter the way they were going
to
um interview the next few witnesses so
if
anything this pause could help the
prosecution absolutely but terry all the
defense is probably doing the same thing
and as we saw it seemed like they almost
had an answer for everything the
prosecutor threw at them
do you think that pro copovich could
walk you know i think this defense
is one of the best teams i have seen so
far they have an answer for
every single thing and i think he could
walk so for instance they say
he's not cold and callous he's just
unemotional he drinks beer he's not an
alcoholic he just works hard
and has to relax at the end of the day
he didn't kill his wife because
she was suicidal so i think they really
have done a great job
at arguing about every single issue that
the prosecution has raised so far
this is going to be an interesting
summation you got to stay tuned thank
you both for contributing
and thank you for joining us here on law
and crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you